[Música]
bienvenidos al momento para hablar de
medio ambiente aquí en france24
desde el 9 de mayo empezó la convención
de la onu contra la desertificación la
cop15 esta es la primera de las tres
convenciones de río que se harán este
año y que también incluyen a la popular
cop del cambio climático y a la de
biodiversidad aunque ésta no es tan
conocida la cumbre es importante porque
intentarán aumentar las metas de
restauración de tierras dañadas y se
prepararán para las sequías todo esto
con un propósito hacerle frente a la
crisis climática y a la pérdida de
ecosistemas de fauna y de flora para eso
decenas de líderes mundiales se reúnen
en abiyán en costa de márfil veremos de
qué se trata la cop15
tierras que se vuelven áridas y secas
sequías prolongadas los efectos son
nefastos entre más se dañan las tierras
escasea más el agua aumenta la
inseguridad alimentaria de la humanidad
y además se pierden herramientas para
combatir el calentamiento global y no es
un escenario poco habitual entre el 20 y
el 40 por ciento de la superficie
terrestre mundial está degradada o se
está degradando en gran medida por la
extracción de recursos naturales y se
estima que para 2050 tres cuartos de la
humanidad estarán afectados por las
sequías por eso imágenes como éstas son
cada vez más comunes
[Música]
lugar y le tutela tersas ya que le
surgen desarme la tierra
eso es la de certificación y el
propósito de la cop15 que se realiza en
costa de marfil es combatirla hasta el
20 de mayo líderes mundiales científicos
y empresarios discutirán cómo restaurar
las tierras dañadas en un programa poco
habitual
jones climático nuestra cumbre se lleva
a cabo en el contexto de una emergencia
climática que está afectando severamente
nuestras políticas de gestión de la
tierra y exacerbando el fenómeno de la
sequía también se lleva a cabo en un
momento en que nuestras economías se ven
debilitadas por los impactos del comit
19 y se sienten los efectos completos
del drama que se vive en ucr harán que
se ayudan y creen
los desafíos se conectan la onu estima
que la restauración de la tierra es
esencial para reducir los gases de
efecto invernadero que calientan el
planeta y para frenar la acelerada
pérdida de biodiversidad
por eso se espera que la cop15 sea un
llamado urgente para aumentar las áreas
naturales tanto en los campos como en
las ciudades además de prepararse para
las sequías y avanzar en la neutralidad
de la degradación de la tierra otro de
los objetivos es que el presupuesto de
la convención de la onu de lucha contra
la desertificación aumente en un 27 por
ciento
una prueba de como la desertificación se
conecta con la crisis climática y la
pérdida de biodiversidad es como las
montañas nevadas se derriten esto está
pasando en lo que se conoce como el
tercer polo ubicado en asia se le llama
así porque sus más de 5 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados lo convierten en la
región más grande de nieve y hielo fuera
del ártico y de la antártida el tercer
polo abarca varios países asiáticos e
incluye la meseta tibetana también
cadenas montañosas como el himalaya el
familia hindú kush o el pie sanz y allí
el calentamiento global es más alto que
el promedio mundial según la primera
evaluación integral que se hizo y que
fue liderada por la onu esto significa
que los glaciares se están derritiendo
más rápido y que cada vez es más común
que los cielos colapsen lo que afecta la
biodiversidad del lugar y pone en riesgo
el recurso de agua dulce de más de 2 mil
millones de personas y a veces incluso
amenaza la vida el 7 de mayo el puente
hassan abbas que une a pakistán con
china colapsó porque el lago glaciar
sisper estalló en medio de la peor por
ola de calor que se ha visto en décadas
en pakistán lo que provocó que el
volumen de agua aumentará un 40% en tan
solo 20 días
estamos esperando que pase el flujo de
agua y también evaluamos el daño al
mismo tiempo de
bloqueo parte de ello que vulnere volteo
nada vamos a todos los que eran
vulnerables en este arroyo y les dimos
raciones de comida por ahora gracias a
dios no hay nadie imponiendo ante shane
y josh y los hielos de la antártida
también se derriten y esto pone en
riesgo al pingüino emperador
esta especie es la que protagoniza la
famosa película de happy feet aunque la
realidad es mucho más dramática el
instituto antártico de argentina cree
que los pingüinos emperador podrían
desaparecer entre 30 o 40 años y es que
el calentamiento global contribuye a que
sea más habitual que se desprendan
pedazos de hielo marino que ponen en
peligro la vida de las crías pues a
diferencia de los pingüinos adelia los
emperador no construyen nidos sino que
se reproducen en el hielo
al desestabilizarse esa plataforma de
hielo
los pingüinos chiquitos que se están los
que están creciendo los océanos pichones
de esa temporada pueden no estar
emplumados no estar preparados para ir
al mar se les desarma el piso sobre el
cual están los apoyados la colonia estas
desarrollándose y si el agua digamos los
alcanzan no están preparados para nadar
no tienen el plumaje impermeable que son
las plumas definitivas de adulto y se
mueren de frío y se ahogan y esto ya
sucedió con la colonia jale y en el mar
de weddell el instituto probó que
durante tres años todos los polluelos de
pingüinos emperador murieron estos son
ejemplos de cómo la desertificación está
conectada con la crisis climática y la
pérdida de biodiversidad por eso es
urgente que se restauren las tierras y
se tomen decisiones determinantes en la
cop15 nosotros nos vemos la próxima
semana para más información ambiental
[Música]